I've got a talent too I'm going to sing
you a song about one of my greatest
passions I saw her on the VHS a sweaty
vision of blonde eNOS abuso pendulous
she's a porn star
a shrieking back in Irish Banshee a
bucking like a Bronco banshee had a
waterproof stay on and she's a porn star
my mom is sad that I couldn't sleep in
her bed so I need a girl who would make
me feel like the king of the world
you know I can't stand the tears so I
got you down on my knees
I'd like to have sex with a porn star
please
I love a tall drink of water dressed in
lingerie I bought her gee you look just
like my daughter : star
hello in LA I kind of place where
grown-ups play but please first side
this NDA misses point star
well bumpin rub black skinnies on
pornhub and when we're through well
watching old tape of me I'm Donahue I
don't like burgers and cheese and I get
to watch her when she pees I like to
have sex with the pornstar please come
on man let's do it
[Music]
the other day I said how about aji said
no way biggest mistake I ever made
said the porn star
I only did it to get on your show I'm
just not into you despite your dough
my daughter's crying so I gotta go send
the porn star
so I crossed my arms in Pride cuz I felt
so small inside I guess I'm all alone on
this asteroid
[Music]